une population sénégalaise de plus en
plus exposés à la montée du corps on a
mis en face à cette situation le
gouvernement a déclaré l'état d'urgence
et un couvre feu nocturne sur l'ensemble
du territoire
pour macky sall président du sénégal ces
mesures visent à freiner l'avancée du
coronavirus dans un pays où 79 cas ont
été recensés en vertu de l'article 69 de
la constitution et de la loi 69,5 du 29
avril 1969 à compter de ce soir à minuit
je déclare l'état d'urgence sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
j'ordonne les forces de défense et de
sécurité de se tenir prêtes en vue de
l'exécution immédiate et stricte des
mesures édictées sur l'étendue du
territoire national d'autres mesures ont
été prises dans le pays
parmi elles la désinfection de l'un des
plus grands marchés de dacca située au
coeur de la médina
celui ci a été démantelée pour un
nettoyage en urgence cette opération est
de grande envergure et a été initiée par
le maire de dakar pour assainir le
marché en accord avec les solutions de
l'état nous sommes en période de
pandémie avec quand un virus qui fait le
tour du globe
et c'est dans ce cadre là que nous avons
lancé cette opération de grande
envergure dans tous les marchés de dakar
aujourd'hui c'est la médina mais les
autres marchés vont suivre autorités
riverains tous veulent s'assurer de bien
lutté contre le corps navires us à
l'image de l' opération de désinfection
du marché ils ne veulent prendre aucun
risque
ce qui nous intéresse c'est seulement le
bien-être des populations
les commerçants viennent prennent leur
argent et s'en vont et laisse les
populations nous on se préoccupe du
bien-être
avec presque 84 confirmé le sénégal est
le pays d'afrique de l'ouest le plus
touché derrière le burkina faso dès ce
vendredi dakar avait annoncé une
fermeture de ses frontières terrestres
et aériennes